Here's the whole program.
Now, compilers have a reputation as being difficult and more complicated than interpreters,
but notice here that the compilers is actually in many ways simpler than the interpreter.
It's fewer lines of code over all.
One reason is because we didn't have to duplicate effort here
of saying first we need constructors to build up a literal
and then within matchset have an interpreter for that literal.
Rather we did it just once.
We said the constructor for literal returns a function which is going to be
the implementation of the compiler for that type of pattern.
It's very concise. Most of these are one-liners.
Maybe I cheated a little bit and I replaced the word "text" with the word "t"
to make it a little bit shorter and fit on one line. There's only one that's complicated.
That's the star of x, because it's recursive.
The ones I haven't listed here is because they're all the same as before.
Before we get into star(x) let me note that.
I didn't have to put down search here, because search is exactly the same as before.
I didn't have to put down plus, because plus is exactly the same as before.
It's defined in terms of star.
What is the definition of star?
One thing we could return is the remainder could be the text itself.
Star of something--you could choose not to take any of it and return the entire text
as the remainder. That's one possibility.
The other possibility is we could apply the pattern x.
From star(x) apply the pattern x to the text and take those sets as remainders.
For every remainder that's not the text itself--
because we already took care of that. We don't need to take care of it again.
For all the remainders that are different from the whole text
then we go through and we apply star(x) to that remainder.
We get a new remainder and that's the result.
That's all we need for the compiler result.
Oh, one piece that was missing is how do interface the match function,
which takes a pattern and a text, with this compiler where a pattern is applied to the text.
That's one line, which is slightly different.
Here before we called matchset.
In the previous implementation we had matchset(pattern, text).
Your job then is to replace that with the proper code for the implementation that calls the compiler.